Pino Audia teaches in the business school at Dartmouth, and he researches something that we took up in an episode of our show a couple weeks ago. He researches the question, how do entrepreneurs get created? And at some point, he noticed that his students and many of his colleagues actually have an opinion about this. They believe entrepreneurs make themselves.
Pino Audia 在达特茅斯商学院任教，他的研究课题正是我们几周前在节目中讨论过的话题。他研究的问题是：企业家是如何诞生的？在研究过程中，他注意到他的学生和许多同事对这个问题都有一个固有的看法。他们认为企业家是靠自己白手起家的。
You know, you head off on your own, you write a business plan, you start in your own garage. And the garage, by the way, is not a metaphorical garage. It is a garage-- a literal garage. Hewlett-Packard started in a garage. Apple Computer had a garage. Disney, the Mattel toy company, the Wham-O toy company.
你知道的，就是你单打独斗，写一份商业计划书，从自家的车库开始创业。顺便说一句，这个“车库”并非比喻，而是真正的车库。惠普（Hewlett-Packard）始于车库，苹果电脑（Apple Computer）始于车库，还有美泰玩具公司（Mattel）、Wham-O 玩具公司等等。
It is about big dreams and humble beginnings, and success in the face of adversity and doubters. And also the idea that, regardless of who you are, regardless of how humble your beginnings are, you can turn something into an immense success story if you work hard. And that was the point in time in which I got interested in the story of the garage as a myth.
这关乎远大的梦想与卑微的起点，关乎在逆境和质疑面前取得成功。这更传达了一种理念：无论你是谁，无论你的起点多么卑微，只要努力工作，你就能把某样东西变成一个巨大的成功故事。正是在那时，我对“车库神话”产生了兴趣。
A garage is a place of possibilities. It's a place where things can get inventive, and a place where entrepreneurs begin.
车库是一个充满可能性的地方。它是一个可以发挥创造力的地方，也是企业家们迈出第一步的地方。
This is from a promotional video that Hewlett Packard put together after it spent millions to buy and restore the original garage where its two founders started what is now the largest technology firm in the world.
这段视频来自惠普公司制作的一部宣传片，当时他们斥资数百万美元买下并修复了最初的那个车库，两位创始人正是在那里创办了现在全球最大的科技公司。
In 1938, in a garage in Palo Alto, California, Bill Hewlett and Dave Packard set to work to start a new company. They had a few hand-operated punches, a used Sears Roebuck drill press that had just made the trip west in the back of one of their cars, and they had a rented flat with a garage.
1938年，在加利福尼亚州帕洛阿尔托市的一个车库里，比尔·休利特（Bill Hewlett）和戴夫·帕卡德（Dave Packard）着手创办了一家新公司。他们只有几台手动冲床，一台二手的西尔斯罗巴克（Sears Roebuck）钻床——刚用他们的车后座从西边运过来，以及一间租来的带有车库的公寓。
Professor Audia doesn't argue with any of this, but he says that when you ask actual entrepreneurs-- and this is true in survey after survey-- you find that most of them began not by going off into their garage, but by working for somebody else, making contacts, learning the business.
奥迪亚教授（Professor Audia）并不反驳这些事实，但他指出，当你询问真正的企业家时——多项调查皆是如此——你会发现他们大多数人创业并非始于车库，而是先为别人打工，积累人脉并学习行业知识。
So this is a very robust finding, which tells us that, actually, if you want to become an entrepreneur, the obvious thing to do is to first go get a job in an industry you're interested in and learn. And then eventually, later, try to create a company.
这是一个非常有力的发现，它告诉我们，如果你想成为一名企业家，显而易见的做法是先去你感兴趣的行业找份工作，不断学习。然后再在未来的某个时间点尝试创立自己的公司。
Even Bill Hewlett and Dave Packard weren't exactly outsiders. They studied electrical engineering at MIT and at Stanford. Packard had worked at General Electric. A former professor of theirs from Stanford gave them leads and hooked them up, for example, with a firm called Litton Engineering, who let them use equipment that they didn't own themselves yet. Just as, decades later, the founders of Apple Computer, 21-year-old Steve Jobs was already working at Atari, and 25-year-old Steve Wozniak was at Hewlett Packard when they started Apple in Jobs' garage.
即使是比尔·休利特和戴夫·帕卡德也不是真正的外行人。他们在麻省理工学院（MIT）和斯坦福大学学习过电气工程。帕卡德曾在通用电气（General Electric）工作过。他们以前在斯坦福的一位教授给他们提供了线索，例如，引荐他们联系了一家名为利顿工程公司（Litton Engineering）的企业，对方允许他们使用自己尚未拥有的设备。正如几十年后，苹果电脑的创始人，21 岁的史蒂夫·乔布斯（Steve Jobs）在创办苹果时已经在雅达利（Atari）工作，而25岁的史蒂夫·沃兹尼亚克（Steve Wozniak）当时在惠普公司工作，这都是在乔布斯的车库里发生的。
And, for example, in the case of Steve Jobs, he benefited greatly from the support that he got from the Atari people, because they introduced him to investors.
例如，在史蒂夫·乔布斯的案例中，他从雅达利（Atari）那边得到的支持中获益良多，因为他们把他介绍给了投资者。
Pino Audia has tried to find mentions of garage entrepreneurs or anything like it in other countries, and didn't come up with much. He says it seems to be a very American idea, very close to other American ideas about opportunity for everybody. The Apple and Hewlett Packard garages have now become such a part of Silicon Valley myth that it's made other tech companies want their own stories like it.
Pino Audia 曾试图在其他国家寻找关于“车库创业者”的记载或类似案例，但几乎一无所获。他认为这似乎是一个非常美国化的概念，与美国关于“人人皆有机会”的理念紧密相连。如今，苹果和惠普的车库已成为硅谷神话的一部分，这使得其他科技公司也渴望拥有属于自己的类似故事。
Google, for example. They did not start in a garage. The founders began working on the search engine in 1996 when they were at Stanford. They didn't actually move into a garage until 1998. They already had investors, and they were just in the garage for five months. But in 2006, Google bought the garage as a company landmark.
比如谷歌（Google）。他们并不是在车库起家的。创始人于1996年在斯坦福大学时就开始研发搜索引擎了。直到1998年，他们才搬进车库。当时他们已经有了投资人，而且只在车库里待了五个月。但到了2006年，谷歌买下了那个车库，将其作为公司的地标。
It's like no one wants to hear the story of the rich, well-connected guys who meet up at the Marriott conference room to hatch a business plan. There's no romance in that.
这就好比没人想听那些富有且人脉广泛的家伙在万豪酒店会议室里策划商业计划的故事。那里面没有任何浪漫色彩。
Dan Heath has written about these origin stories in Fast Company Magazine. He says that one way to measure just how appealing these stories are is to count all the ones that get quoted widely, even though they aren't remotely true. For instance, when eBay began, a story circulated that its founder created the company so his fiancee could buy and collect Pez dispensers more easily. Not true.
丹·希思（Dan Heath）曾在《快公司》（Fast Company）杂志上撰文谈论这些起源故事。他说，衡量这些故事有多吸引人的一种方法，就是去统计那些虽然远非事实，却被广泛引用的故事。例如，eBay 刚创办时，坊间流传一个故事说，创始人创立这家公司是为了让他未婚妻更方便地购买和收藏贝兹（Pez）糖果盒。这并非事实。
One of the creators of YouTube used to claim that the idea for the business came after a dinner party in 2005, where two of the company's masterminds, Chad Hurley and Steve Chen, shot some video and then tried to post it online and found out just how hard that was back then.
YouTube 的一位创始人曾声称，创业灵感来自于2005年的一场晚宴，当时公司的两位策划人查德·赫利（Chad Hurley）和史蒂夫·陈（Steve Chen）拍摄了一些视频，试图上传到网上却发现当时的操作有多么困难。
Now, that is, at a minimum, an exaggerated tale. In fact, there's a third founder of YouTube who claims the dinner party never happened. And Steve Chen later admitted in TIME Magazine that the dinner party was embellished to provide a better founding myth.
这是一个至少被夸大了的故事。实际上，YouTube 的第三位创始人称那场晚宴根本没发生过。史蒂夫·陈后来在《时代》（TIME）杂志上承认，那场晚宴是编造出来的，目的是为了创造一个更出色的创业神话。
And I do want to say that while it feels like a little bit of a let down to realize that this dinner party story is not, you know, the whole truth, I feel like it's a little bit unfair for us to expect more of them than the creation of YouTube. I mean, here's this incredible site, and in some sense, that's not enough for us. Like, we want YouTube to have emerged from some kind of everyday experience. It's like it's not enough to have the value of their work. We also want there to be a really compelling story that started it.
我确实想说，虽然意识到晚宴故事并非全部真相让人感到有点失望，但我觉得如果我们对他们的期待不仅仅是创造了 YouTube，这本身就有点不公平。毕竟，这就是一个不可思议的网站，在某种意义上，这对我们来说还不够。就像我们希望 YouTube 是从某种日常体验中衍生出来的。仅仅拥有他们工作的价值是不够的，我们还希望它背后有一个非常引人入胜的创业故事。
Now, in the article that you wrote for Fast Company, you point out that our attachment to these kinds of mythic creation stories is so strong that we have even exaggerated the Christopher Columbus story.
在你为《快公司》撰写的文章中，你指出我们对这些神话般的创业故事的执着是如此强烈，以至于我们甚至夸大了克里斯托弗·哥伦布（Christopher Columbus）的故事。
Well, Christopher Columbus, as we all know, wanted to prove that he could reach India by sailing west. But no one believed his crazy theory that the Earth was round. And, in fact, his own sailors en route were terrified that they were about to fall over the edge of the Earth, and they almost mutinied. So there's a guy named James Loewen, a professor at University of Vermont, who has pointed out that virtually every element of this story is false. That, in fact, we still don't really know where Christopher Columbus was going.
众所周知，哥伦布想证明他可以通过向西航行到达印度。但当时没人相信他那个“地球是圆的”疯狂理论。事实上，他的水手在航行途中非常惊恐，担心自己会从地球边缘掉下去，甚至差点哗变。佛蒙特大学的詹姆斯·洛温（James Loewen）教授指出，这个故事的几乎每一个元素都是虚假的。事实上，直到今天我们仍然不确定哥伦布当时到底要去哪儿。
There's a lot of disagreement among historians, and even Columbus's best known biographer is totally sure where he was headed. And furthermore, there was no element of "is the Earth round or flat" here. Most people at that time already knew that the Earth was round. The evidence was there for them to see. They noticed that if another ship is receding into the horizon, their hull disappears first, and then the mast later, which implies that there's some kind of curvature in play.
历史学家之间存在很大分歧，即便是哥伦布最著名的传记作者也不确定他的目的地。此外，当时根本不存在“地球是圆的还是平的”的问题。大多数当时的人已经知道地球是圆的了。证据显而易见：他们注意到如果另一艘船正在驶向地平线，船身会先消失，桅杆随后才会消失，这暗示了地球存在某种曲率。
And again, you know, here's a guy who crossed an ocean and became one of the first Europeans to set foot on a new continent, and yet we want more from this guy. We want him to be having hand-to-hand combat with his crew en route. We just crave the drama. We crave the obstacles.
再说一次，这是一个横跨大洋并成为最早踏上新大陆的欧洲人之一的家伙，但我们对他要求的更多。我们希望他在途中与船员进行肉搏战。我们只是渴望戏剧性，渴望障碍。
Well, today on our show, origin stories. We love them so much that sometimes it is hard not to make them up. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. Act One of our show today, Madman. Act Two, Silent Partner. Act Three, Wait, Wait, Don't Film Me. Act Four, Bill Clinton's Seven-Year-Old Brother. Stay with us.
今天我们要讲的是起源故事。我们太爱它们了，以至于有时很难不去编造它们。这里是来自芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》（This American Life）。今天节目的第一幕是“狂人”（Madman）；第二幕是“无声合伙人”（Silent Partner）；第三幕是“等一下，别拍我”（Wait, Wait, Don't Film Me）；第四幕是“比尔·克林顿七岁的弟弟”。敬请收听。
Act One. Well, this first story is about a fight over the origin of certain ideas-- a fight over who really came up with those ideas. Sarah Koenig tells a story about her dad, Julian.
第一幕。第一个故事是关于一场关于某些思想起源的争论——一场关于到底是谁真正想出这些点子的争论。莎拉·凯尼格（Sarah Koenig）讲述了她父亲朱利安（Julian）的故事。
All my life, I've heard the hallmarks of my father's achievements.
我这辈子一直听到我父亲成就的丰碑。
I invented thumb wrestling.
我发明了拇指摔跤。
That was in 1936, when he was a counselor at Camp Greylock for Boys. They already had arm wrestling for the boys, and leg wrestling.
那是1936年，当时他在格雷洛克男童夏令营（Camp Greylock for Boys）担任辅导员。当时孩子们已经有手腕摔跤和腿部摔跤了。
But we needed another wrestling, and I invented thumb wrestling, with the same rules as a hockey puck face-off. One, two, three, go.
但我们需要另一种摔跤，于是我发明了拇指摔跤，规则和冰球争球一样。一、二、三，开始。
It just came to you? Like, just a stroke? Oh, we should use our thumbs?
这是突然想到的？就像灵光一现？哦，我们应该用拇指？
It was a-- yeah. It was just a devastating moment.
这是一个——对，这只是一个改变的时刻。
The discoveries kept coming. Shrimp, for instance.
发现不断涌现。比如虾。
Oh, I popularized shrimp in America.
哦，我在美国推广了虾。
In 1941, my father, a shrimp lover, was discouraged that there were only two places on Broadway in New York where you could get shrimp. So then in Biloxi, Mississippi-- and bear with me here, because this story barely makes any sense-- so he's in Biloxi on his way to Mexico with some buddies. And he sees this government boat about to go out to track the migratory path of shrimp. And he talks his way onto the boat by explaining that he loves shrimp, apparently.
1941年，我父亲是一位虾类爱好者，他很沮丧，因为百老汇只有两家店能吃到虾。于是，在密西西比州的比洛克西（Biloxi）——请忍受我一下，因为这个故事几乎说不通——他当时正和几个哥们儿去墨西哥的路上。他看到一艘政府船只正要出海去追踪虾的迁徙路线。显然，他靠解释自己有多爱吃虾，硬是挤上了那艘船。
And he goes out on this boat, and they find the shrimp breeding grounds or some such. The rest, of course, is history.
他上了那艘船，他们找到了虾的繁殖地之类的东西。剩下的，当然就成了历史。
Then, back in New York, I patrolled Broadway and [INAUDIBLE] asking for shrimp, shrimp, shrimp. More. And in this way, talking it up, I popularized shrimp. No question about it.
回到纽约后，我走遍百老汇，要虾，要虾，还是要虾。更多。就这样，通过到处宣传，我推广了虾。毫无疑问。
That seems like really, really thin evidence that you popularized shrimp in New York.
这证明你在纽约推广了虾的证据看起来真的非常非常薄弱。
Well, I'm not making any claim on the industry.
好吧，我对这个行业没做任何主张。
My dad does make a claim on the word "character," that he came up with the idea to use it to mean a person of unusual or eccentric qualities.
我父亲确实对“性格”（character）这个词拥有主张，称他想出了用这个词来指代一个具有不同寻常或古怪特质的人。
You have a character in a play, of course, but it wasn't in common usage as "he's a character."
你当然可以在戏剧中有一个角色（character），但“他是个性格怪人”这种说法并不常用。
And what made you-- do you remember why you started using it?
是什么促使你——你还记得为什么要开始这样用吗？
I just shifted it, adapted it. But Norman Mailer thinks that he developed it. I take precedence.
我只是转换了它，改编了它。但诺曼·梅勒（Norman Mailer）认为是他开发的。我享有优先权。
According to my father, Norman Mailer also said he invented thumb wrestling. Mailer, who died in 2007, was a famous thumb wrestler, but not its inventor, because as we now know, my dad invented it at Camp Greylock for Boys. And that's the rub. You can't prove the origin of any of this stuff. And it's annoying when people like Norman Mailer take credit.
据我父亲说，诺曼·梅勒也说他发明了拇指摔跤。2007年去世的梅勒是一位著名的拇指摔跤手，但他并非发明者，因为正如我们现在所知，是我父亲在格雷洛克男童夏令营发明的。这就是矛盾所在。你无法证明任何这些东西的起源。当像诺曼·梅勒这样的人抢功时，真的很烦人。
My dad would like people to recognize him for his contributions to shrimp and character and thumb wrestling, but he's not going to make a stink if they don't. His real legacy, though, in advertising, that's another story. That he's willing to fight for, and he has been fighting for it for decades.
我父亲希望人们能认可他对虾、性格和拇指摔跤的贡献，但他如果人们不承认，他也不会大惊小怪。不过，他在广告业的真正遗产又是另一回事了。那是他愿意为之奋斗的，而且他已经奋斗了几十年。
My father was a legendary copy writer. He wrote "Timex Takes a Licking and Keeps on Ticking." He named Earth Day "Earth Day." It falls on his birthday, April 22nd. Earth Day, birthday, so the idea came easily.
我父亲是一位传奇的文案撰稿人。他写出了“天美时经受重击，依然走时准确”（Timex Takes a Licking and Keeps on Ticking）。他命名了“地球日”（Earth Day）。它正好在他生日那天，4月22日。地球日（Earth Day），生日（birthday），所以这个点子很容易就想到了。
The magazine Advertising Age made a list of the top 100 advertising campaigns of the 20th century. The Marlboro Man is on it, and the Energizer Bunny. "Good to the Last Drop" from Maxwell House, and the "Keep America Beautiful" crying Indian.
《广告时代》（Advertising Age）杂志列出了20世纪百大广告活动名单。万宝路男人（Marlboro Man）在名单上，还有劲量兔子（Energizer Bunny）。麦斯威尔咖啡的“滴滴香浓，意犹未尽”（Good to the Last Drop），以及“让美国变得美丽”（Keep America Beautiful）那则印第安人流泪的广告。
But the number one ad-- the top of the 100 list-- "Think Small." That was Volkswagen's American campaign to sell the Beetle in 1959, and my father wrote it. A picture of a tiny car on a big white page and some amused self-deprecating copy.
但排名第一的广告——百大名单榜首——是“想想小”（Think Small）。那是大众汽车（Volkswagen）1959年在美国销售甲壳虫汽车的广告活动，是我父亲写的。一张巨大的白纸上画着一辆小小的汽车，配上一些自嘲的文案。
That ad was followed by Lemon, another VW ad so iconic it made it onto the TV show Mad Men, the show set in 1960 about an ad agency that's slightly behind the times. In this scene, the agency's creative team contemplates the Lemon ad.
那则广告之后是“柠檬”（Lemon），另一则大众汽车广告，它标志性到甚至登上了电视剧《广告狂人》（Mad Men），这是一部以1960年一家稍微有些落后的广告公司为背景的电视剧。在这一幕中，公司的创意团队正在审视那则“柠檬”广告。
I don't know what I hate about it the most-- the ad or the car.
我不知道我最讨厌它什么——是这则广告还是这辆车。
Yeah, they did one last year, same kind of smirk. Remember "Think Small"? It was a half-page ad at a full-page buy. You could barely see the product.
是啊，他们去年做了一个，那种自以为是的 smirk。还记得“想想小”吗？那是在整版版面上只占半版的广告。你几乎看不见产品。
I don't get it.
我不明白。
At the time, these ads were revolutionary. "In the beginning, there was Volkswagen," another famous New York ad man wrote. "That was the day when the new advertising agency was really born."
当时，这些广告具有革命性。“起初，有了大众汽车，”另一位著名的纽约广告人写道。“那一天，真正的现代广告公司诞生了。”
Here's another scene from Mad Men when Don Draper, the agency's creative director, interviews some new talent. After he looks at their portfolio, he hands it back to them with this line.
这是《广告狂人》中的另一幕，当公司创意总监唐·德雷珀（Don Draper）面试一些新人时。在他看完他们的作品集后，他把作品还给他们，并说了这句话。
Looks good. By the way, it has Julian "Konig's" fingerprints all over it.
看起来不错。顺便说一句，这里面到处都有朱利安·“科尼格”（Koenig）的印记。
It's Julian "Kaynig," actually. My father. And what has irritated him for so long is not that he's not recognized for his talent. I mean, the people who write Mad Men clearly know who he is. It's that some of his best work has been claimed by someone else.
其实是朱利安·“凯尼格”（Kaynig）。我的父亲。让他这么多年来感到恼火的并不是他的才华没有得到认可。我的意思是，制作《广告狂人》的人显然知道他是谁。而是他一些最好的作品被别人认领了。
In my instance, the greatest predator on my work was my one-time partner, George Lois, who is the most heralded and talented art director, designer. And his talent is only exceeded by his omnivorous ego. So where it once would have been accepted that the word would be "we" did it, regardless of who originated the work, the word "we" did it evaporated in George's vocabulary, and it became "I."
以我为例，对我作品最大的掠夺者是我的前合伙人乔治·洛伊斯（George Lois），他是最受赞誉、最有才华的美术指导和设计师。他的才华仅次于他那贪婪的自我意识。因此，曾经被接受的说法是“我们”做的，无论作品是谁创作的，但在乔治的词汇表里，“我们”这个词消失了，变成了“我”。
If you've heard of anyone in the advertising industry, it might be George Lois. He's well known for a lot of things, but maybe especially for his provocative and funny Esquire magazine covers from the 1960s, like the one of Muhammad Ali posing as Saint Sebastian. But before that, George Lois worked at Doyle Dane Bernbach, and so did my father. In 1960, they both left DDB and joined up with another guy, Fred Papert, to form their own upstart agency called PKL-- Papert, Koenig, and Lois.
如果你听说过广告界的任何人，那可能就是乔治·洛伊斯。他以很多事情出名，但可能最出名的是他在20世纪60年代那些挑衅且有趣的《时尚先生》（Esquire）杂志封面，比如穆罕默德·阿里（Muhammad Ali）模仿圣塞巴斯蒂安的那一期。但在那之前，乔治·洛伊斯在 DDB 广告公司工作，我父亲也在那。1960年，他们都离开了 DDB，并与另一个人弗雷德·帕佩特（Fred Papert）联手组建了自己的新兴代理公司 PKL——帕佩特、科尼格和洛伊斯（Papert, Koenig, and Lois）。
George Lois wouldn't talk to me for this story. "I'm not going to get into a sophomoric [BLEEP] fight with a disgruntled ex-partner," he wrote in an email. I can't say I blame him. I've had mixed feelings about this fight.
乔治·洛伊斯不愿接受我的采访。“我不会和一个心怀不满的前合伙人陷入那种幼稚的废话争斗，”他在电子邮件中写道。我不能怪他。对于这场争斗，我的心情很复杂。
Of course I want to stick up for my father, take his side. But I've also thought there's something inherently undignified about the whole thing. Like it's beneath my father to care whether or not George Lois is taking credit for this or that slogan from 1962. So I never really paid attention to the details-- until now. Lately, it's been coming up more, or at least more publicly, so I started asking questions.
当然，我希望能支持我的父亲，站在他那一边。但我也觉得整件事本身就显得有些不够体面。仿佛我父亲去在乎乔治·洛伊斯是否抢走了1962年这个或那个口号的功劳，这有失身份。所以我从未真正关注过细节——直到现在。最近，这件事被提起的次数越来越多，至少在公开场合如此，所以我开始询问细节。
According to my father, it all started with the Harvey Probber account. Harvey Probber made elegant modern furniture, and my dad says he came up with the ad-- a beautiful chair with a matchbook under one leg and the line, "if your Harvey Probber chair wobbles, straighten your floor," and a piece of copy that went with it that he thought was very good.
据我父亲说，这一切始于哈维·普罗伯（Harvey Probber）的客户账户。哈维·普罗伯制作优雅的现代家具，我父亲说他想出了那个广告创意——一张精美的椅子，下面塞着一本火柴书，配文是：“如果你的哈维·普罗伯椅子摇晃，请把你的地板弄平”，还有一段他认为写得非常好的文案。
And a year or so later, or a couple of years later, Ron Holland, a friend of mine, came running into my office to say, George is upstairs with a Japanese editorial writer. They're doing an interview with him, and he's claiming your Harvey Probber chair ad-- that he wrote it.
一年左右，或者两年后，我的朋友罗恩·霍兰德（Ron Holland）跑进我的办公室说，乔治正在楼上接受一位日本编辑的采访。他们正在对他进行采访，他声称你的哈维·普罗伯椅子广告——是他写的。
So I called George down to my office and remonstrated-- that's what men do frequently-- with him. And he says, I never said that. I would never say that. And he went back to his office. And a little while later, Ron comes bursting into my office saying, George said, I told that son of a gun where to get off!
所以我把乔治叫到我的办公室，对他进行了责备——这是男人经常做的事。他说，我没说过那样的话。我绝不会那样说。然后他回到了自己的办公室。不久之后，罗恩冲进我的办公室说，乔治说，我告诉那个混蛋去哪儿了！
Meaning you. Meaning he had told you.
意思是说你。意思是说他已经告诉了你。
Told me where to get off. So that was really the start of it.
告诉我该走人了。所以那真的是这件事的开端。
In 1972, George Lois published a book, the first of many, about his career, called George, Be Careful. In it, he describes going to the Harvey Probber furniture factory in Massachusetts with my dad. "Each chair was placed on an electronic test platform to be sure it was absolutely level," Lois wrote. "'Got a book of matches?' I asked Julian, a heavy smoker.
1972年，乔治·洛伊斯出版了一本书，是他职业生涯中众多书籍中的第一本，书名是《乔治，小心点》（George, Be Careful）。他在书中描述了和父亲去马萨诸塞州的哈维·普罗伯家具工厂。“每一把椅子都被放在一个电子测试平台上，以确保它绝对水平，”洛伊斯写道。“‘有火柴吗？’我问朱利安，他是个大烟鬼。”
He handed me a matchbook, and I slid it under one leg of the chair on the test platform. 'I've got the ad,' I said. If your Harvey Probber chair is crooked, straighten your floor.' Julian scowled and shot back, 'Ass [BLEEP], If your Harvey Probber chair wobbles, straighten your floor.' That was the way the ad ran, and that was the way we built the first red-hot creative agency."
“他递给我一本火柴书，我把它塞在测试平台上椅子的其中一条腿下。‘我有广告词了，’我说。‘如果你的哈维·普罗伯椅子歪了，就把你的地板弄平。’朱利安皱着眉头回击道，‘屁话，如果你的哈维·普罗伯椅子摇晃，就把你的地板弄平。’那就是广告运行的方式，也是我们建立第一家红极一时的创意代理公司的方式。”
And none of that ever happened as described by George. He didn't ask me for a matchbook. He didn't slide it under the leg of a chair. He didn't say, I've got the ad. None of it is true.
这些内容完全没有按乔治描述的那样发生。他没向我要火柴书。他没把它塞在椅子腿下。他没说，我有广告词了。没有一个是真的。
But his makes a better story.
但他的版本讲得更好。
His is a marvelous story. George is a talented storyteller with a vivid imagination. The only thing that could exceed it would be the truth.
他的故事很精彩。乔治是一位天才的讲故事者，拥有丰富的想象力。唯一能超越它的只有真相。
There are other instances, also regarding ads that were groundbreaking for their time. A campaign for the New York Herald Tribune, "Who says a good newspaper has to be dull?" Some famous Xerox commercials showing a little girl operating a copy machine, and later, a chimpanzee doing it. [? An ad ?] several people who worked on the account have complained that George literally had nothing to do with.
还有其他例子，同样涉及当时具有开创性的广告。为《纽约先驱论坛报》（New York Herald Tribune）做的活动，“谁说一份好的报纸一定是沉闷的？”一些著名的施乐（Xerox）广告，展示了一个小女孩操作复印机，后来还有一只黑猩猩在操作。几位为该项目工作过的人抱怨说，乔治实际上与此毫无关系。
Then there's the ad for Coldene cough medicine. The page is entirely black with just two quotes at different heights, meant to show a couple talking in bed. "John, is that Billy coughing?" says the wife. "Get up and give him some Coldene," the husband replies.
还有 Coldene 止咳药的广告。整页都是黑色的，只有两句报价，位置高低不同，旨在展示一对夫妻在床上说话。“约翰，是比利在咳嗽吗？”妻子说。“起来给他喂点 Coldene，”丈夫回答。
In an interview 20 years later, George Lois said, "The idea for the ad hit me like a brainstorm. This was the first time there would be no copy, no package design, no trademark," he said. "It was really the beginning of a new creative revolution. It was one of those ads that made history, effectively." Again, my dad is adamant that the whole ad, copy and design, were his.
20年后的一次采访中，乔治·洛伊斯说：“这则广告的灵感像头脑风暴一样击中了我。这是第一次没有文案，没有包装设计，没有商标，”他说。“这真的是一场新创意革命的开始。这确实是载入史册的广告之一。”再一次，我父亲坚持认为整则广告，包括文案和设计，都是他的。
There are many possibilities here of what's going on. George Lois could be lying. Or George Lois could have convinced himself in some way that what he's saying about all this stuff is true. Or my dad could be doing the same thing-- remembering stuff that happened when it didn't happen. Or, I suppose, my dad could be lying.
关于正在发生什么，这里有很多可能性。乔治·洛伊斯可能在撒谎。或者乔治·洛伊斯在某种程度上已经让自己相信他所说的一切都是真的。或者我父亲也可能在做同样的事——记住了并没有发生的事情。或者，我想，我父亲也可能在撒谎。
I'd worry about those latter options more if my father was the only one disputing George Lois's version of history, but he's not. There's the photographer Carl Fisher, who worked with George Lois for more than 30 years, and shot many of the most famous Esquire covers. Carl Fisher says George has taken credit for cover ideas and photographs that were Carl's, and talked in detail about certain photoshoots.
如果只有我父亲在质疑乔治·洛伊斯的历史版本，我会更担心后面的选择，但他不是唯一的。摄影师卡尔·费舍尔（Carl Fisher）与乔治·洛伊斯共事超过30年，拍摄了许多最著名的《时尚先生》封面。卡尔·费舍尔说乔治窃取了封面创意和照片的功劳，卡尔详细讲述了某些拍摄过程。
Like about flying to Las Vegas to shoot the boxer Sonny Liston as Santa, and even placing the Santa cap on Liston's head. Or rushing Italian actress Virna Lisi into a photoshoot in New York for this famous cover where she's pretending to shave her face. But Fisher says George wasn't there for either shoot. In fact, the Lisi shoot happened in Rome, and he still has the receipts to prove it.
比如飞往拉斯维加斯拍摄拳击手桑尼·利斯顿（Sonny Liston）扮演圣诞老人的照片，甚至是他亲自把圣诞帽戴在利斯顿头上的。或者把意大利女演员维娜·丽丝（Virna Lisi）匆忙带到纽约拍摄这张著名的封面，她在照片中假装在刮脸。但费舍尔说乔治根本没出现在拍摄现场。事实上，丽丝的拍摄是在罗马进行的，他甚至还有收据来证明。
And then there's Shelley Zalaznick, the first editor of New York Magazine. George once told a reporter, quote, "My hand on the Bible, I, George Lois, created New York Magazine." Mr. Zalaznick says that's simply not true. He himself remembers making the first dummy front page one hot August night in 1963.
还有雪莉·扎拉兹尼克（Shelley Zalaznick），《纽约杂志》（New York Magazine）的第一任编辑。乔治曾对记者说，引用：“我对上帝发誓，我，乔治·洛伊斯，创立了《纽约杂志》。”扎拉兹尼克先生说那根本不是真的。他自己清楚记得在1963年8月一个炎热的夜晚，他亲自制作了第一份封面小样。
Not only that-- he's never met George Lois. "As for George's version," he told me, "I'm at a loss. I don't know why grownups do things like this."
不仅如此——他从未见过乔治·洛伊斯。“至于乔治的版本，”他告诉我，“我感到很困惑。我不知道成年人为什么会做这样的事。”
But the story my father objects to the most isn't about ad copy at all. It's personal. Papert, Koenig, and Lois had gotten the Dutch Master Cigar account, and their TV spokesman at the time was this famous comedian, Ernie Kovacs. So my dad flew out to LA to meet him, and they hit it off.
但我父亲最反对的那个故事根本不是关于广告文案的。那是私人的事。帕佩特、科尼格和洛伊斯拿下了荷兰大师雪茄（Dutch Master Cigar）的账户，他们当时的电视代言人是著名的喜剧演员厄尼·科瓦奇（Ernie Kovacs）。所以我父亲飞到洛杉矶去见他，他们很投缘。
And Ernie and I spent the day together, driving around, and lunched together. End of the afternoon, in the lobby of the hotel I was saying in, the Beverly Hilton, he was not allowed past the lobby, because he had short pants on. And then he went off to go to a party that night. And on his way home, there being a rain, his car skidded and went into a pole, and Ernie killed himself.
厄尼和我在一起度过了一天，开车四处逛，一起吃午饭。那天下午晚些时候，在我住的酒店——比佛利希尔顿酒店（Beverly Hilton）大堂，他因为穿着短裤而不被允许进入大堂。然后那天晚上他去参加了一个聚会。在回家的路上，因为下雨，他的车打滑撞上了一根电线杆，厄尼就这样自杀了。
I was on a plane back to New York and learned about it the next morning. So, unfortunate incident, but certainly memorable to me. And lo and behold.
我在飞回纽约的飞机上，第二天早上才知道这件事。所以，这是一个不幸的意外，但对我来说确实令人难忘。然后，看看，出现了什么。
Lo and behold, in his 2005 book, $elebrities which is spelled with a dollar sign instead of a C at the beginning, George tells the story of his lovely lunch with Ernie, his car ride to the airport with Ernie, his red eye flight back to New York, and his learning the following morning from a stack of still-bound newspapers that Ernie had been killed in a car crash. My father has tried to fight back, aggressively at times. For instance, after the Ernie Kovacs story appeared in $elebrities , my dad retaliated in the medium he knows best. He wrote an ad.
看啊，在他2005年的书《名流》（$elebrities，开头的C被替换成了美元符号）中，乔治讲述了他和厄尼共进午餐的故事，他开车送厄尼去机场的故事，他连夜飞回纽约的故事，以及他第二天早上从一叠还未装订的报纸上得知厄尼死于车祸的故事。我父亲试图回击，有时甚至很激烈。例如，在厄尼·科瓦奇的故事出现在《名流》之后，我父亲用他最擅长的媒介进行了回击。他写了一则广告。
I wrote an ad, "Low, Lower, Lois."
我写了一则广告，“低，更低，洛伊斯”（Low, Lower, Lois）。
That's Lois, L-O-I-S.
那是洛伊斯，L-O-I-S。
And I wanted to print it in the New York Times as a book review. A public service book review.
我想把它印在《纽约时报》上作为书评。一个公益书评。
The Times didn't run it, but it did run in Adweek, though toward the back of the magazine, and it got no response. Over the years, he and some of his former colleagues have written to reporters at the New York Times and other places, trying to correct the record. But their letters have mostly been ignored.
《时报》没登，但它在《广告周刊》（Adweek）上刊登了，尽管是在杂志后面，而且没有得到任何回应。多年来，他和一些前同事曾写信给《纽约时报》和其他地方的记者，试图纠正记录。但他们的信大多被忽略了。
Just last year, a Times story about an exhibit of George Lois's Esquire covers credited him, in the very first paragraph, with "Think Small," the Xerox ads with the chimp, and a couple of other campaigns people say George either didn't originate or didn't even work on. Finally, the Times printed a short correction, giving "Think Small" back to my dad. But it was a small victory, three weeks after the fact. In the mid-'80s, my dad wrote a letter to George directly, threatening to sue, it seems, and received a letter back calling him a sad, tortured and tragic figure.
就在去年，《时报》的一篇关于乔治·洛伊斯《时尚先生》封面展的报道在第一段就将“Think Small”、那则带黑猩猩的施乐广告以及其他一些人们认为乔治并未参与或根本没做过的广告归功于他。最终，《时报》刊登了一则简短的更正，把“Think Small”还给了我父亲。但那是一次小小的胜利，已经是事实发生三周后的事了。80年代中期，我父亲直接写信给乔治，似乎威胁要起诉他，结果收到了回信，称他是一个悲伤、痛苦且悲剧性的人物。
All in all, my father's efforts haven't really done the damage he's hoped, or really, any damage at all. He's an indignant Basset Hound, nipping at the heels of the media's Great Dane. George Lois is a good talker with an engaging personality, and he's become something of a spokesman for the advertising industry. There are quotes in the newspaper, and magazine profiles, exhibits, books.
总而言之，我父亲的努力并没有造成他希望的那种损害，或者说，根本没造成任何损害。他是一只义愤填膺的巴吉度猎犬，咬着媒体那头大丹犬的后脚跟。乔治·洛伊斯是一个善于言谈、性格迷人的人，他已成为广告业的某种代言人。报纸上有语录，杂志上有专访，展览，书籍。
Errors printed once are repeated and repeated. So if you look up "Think Small" on the internet, for instance, you'll find it attributed to Julian Koenig, but you're also likely to learn that George Lois wrote it.
一旦打印出的错误会被反复重复。所以如果你在网上查“Think Small”，你会发现它归功于朱利安·科尼格，但你也很可能会了解到乔治·洛伊斯写了它。
I liked the way he took credit for accounts he never had anything to do with, because that made it almost comical. All the Xerox stuff-- Xerox was an account that I got-- was done by Sam Scali and I think Mike Chapell. And George, at the end, started taking credit for that, too.
我喜欢他因为那几乎显得滑稽，而去认领他从未参与过的账户。所有施乐的东西——施乐是我得到的账户——都是由萨姆·斯卡利（Sam Scali）和迈克·查佩尔（Mike Chapell）做的。最后乔治也开始把功劳揽在自己身上。
That's Fred Papert, the P of PKL. He was the guy who recruited Lois and Koenig to make a new agency in 1960. Now he's one of the guys responsible for redeveloping Times Square as president of the 42nd Street Development Corporation. He knows the stories all too well-- Xerox, Harvey Probber, Coldene, Ernie Kovacs, even.
那是弗雷德·帕佩特（Fred Papert），PKL 中的 P。他就是在1960年招募洛伊斯和科尼格创建新代理公司的那个人。现在，作为第42街开发公司（42nd Street Development Corporation）的总裁，他是负责重建时代广场的人之一。他太了解这些故事了——施乐、哈维·普罗伯、Coldene、厄尼·科瓦奇，甚至是。
It's nuts. I think he's really got a screw loose. I think George truly doesn't know what he's doing. But it's nutty on both sides.
这太疯狂了。我想他真的是脑子进水了。我觉得乔治真的不知道自己在干什么。但这双方都挺疯狂的。
Fred's in my dad's camp, in so far as he knows and believes my dad is telling the truth. But his support more or less stops there. and he's categorical on this point-- that my dad is himself acting like a nut, wasting his time. They've talked about this on rides to and from the racetrack.
弗雷德站在我父亲这一边，因为他知道并相信我父亲说的是真话。但他的支持也就到此为止了——他在这一点上非常明确——他认为我父亲自己也表现得像个疯子，在浪费时间。他们在往返赛马场的路上谈论过这件事。
The reason that Julian should not be fussing about this stuff at this stage is A, nobody gives a [BLEEP]. B, anybody that would give a [BLEEP] knows already what it's about. This is what George does. It's George's thing.
朱利安在这个阶段不应该再为这些事大惊小怪的原因是：A，没人会在意。B，任何会在意的人都已经知道真相了。这就是乔治的风格。这是乔治的套路。
And they just got to put a lid on it. But I've had this conversation with him 100 times, and he gets really pissed off. So I know he's got a screw loose, too. Your father can be a pain in the ass, you know, and even be pesty if you say to him, Julian, [BLEEP] off already. We've heard this story. We know about the wobbling chair or the wobbling floor-- I've forgotten which one.
他们只需要闭嘴就行了。但我已经和他进行过100次这样的谈话了，他真的会很生气。所以我知道他的脑子也进水了。你知道，你父亲有时会很烦人，甚至有点让人讨厌，如果你对他说，朱利安，滚远点吧。我们已经听过这个故事了。我们知道关于那把晃动的椅子或者晃动的地板的事——我都忘了是哪个了。
You have no idea how many letters we wrote to the New York Times, to Advertising Age, to this and that. This is a dialogue between old farts. Julian's in another world from these kinds of things. Julian is one of the great thinkers and creators in the advertising business. If some nutcase claims credit, who cares?
你无法想象我们给《纽约时报》、《广告时代》以及其他地方写了多少封信。这是老头子之间的对话。朱利安生活在与这些事情完全不同的世界里。朱利安是广告界伟大的思想家和创作者之一。如果某个疯子声称拥有功劳，谁在乎呢？
And he doesn't even really like me very much. You have to understand that that's where we start. Well, it's true. I think he goes to the races with me because I have a car.
而且他其实也不太喜欢我。你必须明白这一点。好吧，是真的。我想他和我一起去赛马是因为我有车。
My father recognizes that there are only about four people left on Earth who care about this stuff. It's just that he happens to be one of them, and he cannot let it go.
我父亲承认世界上只剩下大约四个人关心这些事了。只是他正好是其中之一，而且他无法释怀。
I assume if I had a different personality, I would say, I know what I've done. And those dear and near to me know what I have done or not done, and let it go at that. But I'm a fallible fellow, and obviously, with ego of his own, and I resent being burgled.
我想如果我有不同的性格，我会说，我知道我做了什么。那些亲近我的人也知道我做了什么或没做什么，就这样算了吧。但我是一个会犯错的人，显然，他也有自己的自尊心，我讨厌被抢走劳动成果。
The odd thing about all this, as my older brother John points out, is that my father's never exactly been a champion of advertising.
正如我哥哥约翰所指出的，这一切最奇怪的事情是，我父亲从来都不是广告界的拥护者。
And he never believed. He wasn't a true believer in the business. I mean, I remember him saying to me as a kid, you know, if you don't find something you want to do and really work at it, you're going to end up like me. A writer of short sentences. That's verbatim.
他从来不相信。他不是这个行业的真正信徒。我的意思是，我记得我小时候他对我说，你知道，如果你找不到你想做的事情并真正为之努力，你最终会像我一样。一个只会写短句的人。那是原话。
And so it's a little ironic, you know? Because he didn't care. That's the thing, Sarah. All those years, he didn't care, because I think he thought it was beneath him.
所以这有点讽刺，你知道吗？因为他不在乎。就是这样，莎拉。那些年来，他不在乎，因为我想他觉得这有失身份。
And the business, in some ways, was not beneath him, but was not serious enough to care that much about. And now he does.
而且在某些方面，这个行业并不比他低，但也没严重到让他那么在乎。而现在，他在乎了。
I understand why he cares. He's 88 years old now, so his legacy, understandably, is on his mind. And even though he did campaigns for all sorts of good causes-- gun control, nuclear proliferation, Robert Kennedy's senatorial and presidential campaigns-- my father's not quite satisfied with his life's work.
我明白他为什么在乎。他现在88岁了，所以他的遗产，可以理解，就在他心头。虽然他为各种公益事业做过广告——枪支管制、核扩散、罗伯特·肯尼迪（Robert Kennedy）的参议员和总统竞选——但我父亲对他的终身工作并不完全满意。
Advertising is built on puffery, on, at heart, deception, and I don't think anybody can go proudly into the next world with a career built on deception, even though no matter how well they do it.
广告建立在吹捧上，在本质上是欺骗，我不认为任何人能带着一份建立在欺骗之上的职业骄傲地进入下一个世界，无论他们做得多好。
You're not necessarily proud that you had a career in the field of advertising and that's your legacy, but you are proud that you were the best in the business at the thing you chose to do.
你不一定因为你在广告领域从事过职业并将其作为遗产而感到自豪，但你为自己能在所选择的行业做到最好而感到自豪。
I couldn't have said it better myself.
我自己都说不出更好的了。
If he could go back, choose another career, my father would like to have been an environmentalist of some kind, which is why he'd really like to be remembered for something almost nobody knows he did-- naming Earth Day. It agitated him to look up Earth Day on Wikipedia recently and not see his name anywhere. So a few days ago, I added it.
如果能回去，选择另一个职业，我父亲希望能成为某种环境保护主义者，这就是为什么他真的很想因为一件几乎没人知道是他做的事而被记住——命名地球日。最近在维基百科上查地球日却没看到自己的名字，这让他很激动。所以几天前，我加上去了。
We first ran this story back in 2009. Sarah's dad, Julian Koenig, just recently died in June. He was 93.
我们早在2009年就首次播出了这个故事。莎拉的父亲朱利安·科尼格在今年6月刚刚去世。他93岁。
Sarah Koenig is one of the producers of our program. In two weeks, we're actually launching a brand new show, and Sarah is the host of that show. Yes, This American Life is putting out a second weekly program.
莎拉·科尼格是我们节目的制片人之一。两周后，我们将推出一个全新的节目，莎拉是那个节目的主持人。是的，《美国生活》正在推出第二个每周节目。
We have a new show. It's a podcast. It's called Serial. The idea is that instead of different stories and a different theme each week, every episode of Serial brings you back to the same story, and you hear the next chapter.
我们有一个新节目。是一个播客。它叫《Serial》。它的概念是，不是每周讲不同的故事和主题，每一集《Serial》都会带你回到同一个故事，听下一章。
We've been working on this for a year. We are very excited to bring it to you. We are giving you two episodes to start.
我们为此努力了一年。我们非常兴奋能把它带给你。我们先提供两集给你们。
It's in two weeks. October 3rd. You can sign up for free downloads and hear a sneak preview at serialpodcast.org, or on the iTunes store. That's serialpodcast.org, spelled not like the breakfast food.
两周后。10月3日。你可以在 serialpodcast.org 或 iTunes 商店免费订阅下载并试听预告。那是 serialpodcast.org，拼写不像早餐食品（cereal）。
Coming up, Peter Sagal, long before Wait, Wait, Don't Tell Me, his lost years in Havana. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
接下来，彼得·萨加尔（Peter Sagal），在《等一下，别告诉我》（Wait, Wait, Don't Tell Me）之前，他在哈瓦那的那些迷失岁月。一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Each week on our program, we choose a theme, bring you different kinds of stories on that theme. Today's show, Origin Stories, where we go back to figure out where things came from. We've arrived at Act Two of our program. Act Two, Silent Partner. One of our producers, Sean Cole, visited Chad's Trading Post, a restaurant filled with frilly knickknacks in Southampton, Massachusetts. It's a restaurant with a very distinct origin story.
这里是《美国生活》。我是艾拉·格拉斯（Ira Glass）。每周我们选择一个主题，带给你关于那个主题的不同故事。今天的节目，“起源故事”，我们回到过去去寻找事情的起源。我们已经进入了节目的第二幕。第二幕，“无声合伙人”。我们的制片人之一肖恩·科尔（Sean Cole）访问了位于马萨诸塞州南安普敦、满是蕾丝小饰品的餐馆“查德的交易站”（Chad's Trading Post）。这是一个拥有非常独特起源故事的餐馆。
The first time my girlfriend Mary Ellen and I walked into Chad's Trading Post, she noticed that only boys work there, and thought it was weird. Normally, she said, in a place like this, a small country restaurant, you only see girls working. She pointed to the cover of the menu, which read, "Dedicated to and operated proudly in the memory of Chad D. McDonald, 3/12/74 to 3/11/90."
我和我女友玛丽·艾伦（Mary Ellen）第一次走进“查德的交易站”时，她注意到那里只招男员工，觉得很奇怪。她说，通常在这种地方，一个小乡村餐馆，你只会看到女性工作。她指着菜单封面，上面写着：“诚挚奉献并纪念查德·D·麦克唐纳（Chad D. McDonald），1974年3月12日至1990年3月11日运营。”
She leaned in to me and whispered, do you think the owner hires only boys because they remind her of her son? I certainly thought this was possible, and sad, in a way that makes you feel embarrassed for that person. Then a man came over and poured us some coffee.
她凑到我耳边低声说，你觉得老板只招男生是因为他们提醒她想起了儿子吗？我当然认为这是可能的，而且很悲伤，让人为那个人感到尴尬。然后一个男人过来给我们倒了咖啡。
And when he turned around, there, in huge white letters, on the back of his blue polo shirt, it said, Chad's brother. Do you think that's what they call all the managers here, I asked Mary Ellen. Do you think that's really Chad's brother? Then another friendlier manager type came over and asked us how we were doing, and if we needed more coffee. And I noticed his shirt.
当他转过身时，在蓝色 Polo 衫背面印着巨大的白色字母，写着“查德的兄弟”。你觉得那是他们称呼那里所有经理的方式吗？我问玛丽·艾伦。你觉得那真的是查德的兄弟吗？然后另一位更友好的经理走过来，问我们怎么样，是否需要更多咖啡。我注意到了他的衬衫。
My shirt says "Chad's best friend." Logo over on the right hand side. And it just tells the customers who we are. Yeah, Chad's best friend, yeah, Chad's brother, Chad's dad. And we had Chad's mom, too, but she's doing other things.
我的衬衫上写着“查德最好的朋友”。右侧有标识。它只是告诉顾客我们是谁。是的，查德最好的朋友，是的，查德的兄弟，查德的爸爸。我们还有查德的妈妈，但她在忙别的。
This is the story of Chad's Trading Post. From the time he was 12, Chad and his brothers and a few friends had always talked about starting a small restaurant together when they graduated high school. They planned out menus. Chad's father took him looking for locations. But Chad died in a shooting accident two days before his 16th birthday.
这就是查德交易站的故事。从查德12岁开始，他和他的兄弟们还有几个朋友就一直谈论着高中毕业后一起开一家小餐馆。他们规划菜单。查德的父亲带他去寻找地点。但查德在16岁生日前两天在一场枪击事故中去世了。
Chad's father Glenn, his brothers Scott and Cory, and his best friend Mike tell the story.
查德的父亲格伦（Glenn）、他的兄弟斯科特（Scott）和科里（Cory），以及他最好的朋友迈克（Mike）讲述了这个故事。
The boy who shot and killed my son was his younger brother's best friend.
那个开枪打死我儿子的男孩是我小儿子的好朋友。
It was myself and my best friend at the time and Chad. And they were cleaning up the cellar for his birthday. No, you were there too, yeah.
那当时是我和当时最好的朋友还有查德。他们正在为他的生日清理地下室。不，你也在那里，是的。
Yeah. We were in the kitchen cooking sausage.
是的。我们在厨房里做香肠。
Yeah. We were cooking dinner. But they were downstairs cleaning, and I was upstairs. My mother had just left, and me and Cory were upstairs cooking dinner.
是的。我们在做晚饭。但他们下楼去打扫，我在楼上。我母亲刚走，我和科里在楼上做饭。
And they came up for a break, went into the room, and then we heard, like, a little firecracker go off. You know? And then the person came out of the room and he had blood on his hands, and he was freaking out. "I shot Chad, I shot Chad."
他们上来休息，进了房间，然后我们听到了像小鞭炮一样的声音。你知道吗？然后那个人从房间里出来，手上带着血，他快疯了。“我杀了查德，我杀了查德。”
The official ruling, which was that Chad picked up a gun, pointed it at this fellow, said bang. The other fellow picked up a gun, pointed it back at Chad, pulled the trigger, and that was all.
官方的判决是，查德捡起一把枪，指着这个家伙，说了“砰”。对方也捡起一把枪，指回查德，扣动了扳机，就是这样。
So I called 911. And then I paged my mother. And then the police got there.
所以我打了911。然后我传呼了我母亲。然后警察赶到了。
I was charged for involuntary manslaughter, because it was my handgun that ultimately killed Chad, and that I was not aware that he had two of my handguns out of my cabinet in his bedroom at the time. And, frankly, that was something I should have been aware of.
我被控过失杀人罪，因为最终杀死查德的是我的手枪，而且我并不知道当时他在卧室的柜子里拿出了我的两把手枪。说实话，那是我应该意识到的。
In 1993, the year Chad would have graduated from high school, the year he and Mike and his brothers and his father had planned to open a restaurant, they decided to open Chad's Trading Post.
1993年，查德本该高中毕业的那一年，也是他和迈克、他的兄弟们还有他父亲计划开餐馆的那一年，他们决定开设“查德的交易站”。
This is Chad's corner of the restaurant. Notice the menu board. It tells you, welcome to Chad's Trading Post Family Restaurant. It says "nobody leaves hungry," and lists all the specials of the day. It also has a claimer on the bottom that's Named in Memory of Chad D. McDonald, and the date of his birth, which was 3/12/74.
这是餐馆里的查德角。注意菜单板。它告诉你，欢迎来到“查德的交易站家庭餐馆”。上面写着“没人会饿着肚子离开”，并列出了当天的特色菜。底部还有一个声明，是以纪念查德·D·麦克唐纳命名，以及他的出生日期，即1974年3月12日。
In all of the interviews I've ever heard and seen of an emotional nature, the person answering questions doesn't begin to cry until well into the interview. Chad's dad began crying before I even turned on my tape recorder. I asked him for a quick tour of the restaurant.
在我听过和看过的所有带有情感色彩的采访中，被访者直到采访进行到很久之后才会开始哭。查德的父亲在我打开录音机之前就开始哭了。我让他带我快速参观一下餐馆。
It's a nice place-- homey, even froofy, though all the men who created it are tattooed, muscly, working-class guys, Chad's father included.
这是一个不错的地方——家庭化，甚至有点浮夸，尽管创造它的男人们都有纹身、肌肉发达，属于工人阶级，包括查德的父亲。
To the left of that, it shows you the last and most recent picture of my son, which was taken about six weeks before he died. And the picture of the two boys that were named in memory of him, his younger brother's son, who is Ian Chadwick, and his best friend's son, who is named Chad Michael.
在那左边，展示了我儿子最后也是最近的一张照片，是在他去世前六周左右拍的。还有两个以纪念他命名的男孩的照片，他弟弟的儿子，名叫伊恩·查德威克（Ian Chadwick），还有他最好的朋友的儿子，名叫查德·迈克尔（Chad Michael）。
This photo originally showed the two babies in Glenn's arms, but they had the photographer alter the photo, insert Chad's head over Glenn's.
这张照片最初显示两个婴儿在格伦怀里，但他们让摄影师修改了照片，把查德的头贴在格伦怀里。
And what they did was took the picture and replaced, by computer, Chad's picture over mine. It's actually my arms holding him, but the rest of it's all Chad.
他们所做的是用电脑把照片替换了，用查德的图片覆盖了我的。其实是我怀抱着他，但照片剩下的部分全是查德。
Glenn showed me a painting in another corner of the restaurant. It was the comedy and tragedy masks from the cover of Motley Crue's album Theater of Pain, Chad's favorite record. After he died, Chad's friends and brothers adapted the design into a memorial to him.
格伦在餐馆的另一个角落给我看了一幅画。那是克鲁小丑乐队（Motley Crue）专辑《痛苦剧院》（Theater of Pain）封面上那两个喜剧和悲剧面具，那是查德最喜欢的唱片。他去世后，查德的朋友和兄弟们把这个设计改成了对他的纪念。
It appears on their shirts. Two brass masks hang over the door, smiling and frowning. A huge flag with the masks hangs in the breeze outside, too heavy to flutter. Chad's brother Scott calls them "the faces."
它出现在他们的衬衫上。两个黄铜面具挂在门上，一个笑，一个皱眉。一面巨大的面具旗帜也在外面随风飘动，因为太重而无法拍打。查德的兄弟斯科特称它们为“面孔”。
This was my first tattoo. I got the comedy and tragedy faces, with the "In memory of Chad" banner, and that was my first tattoo. And I got that for the obvious reason. That's pretty much the family symbol now. It started off with my father getting it.
这是我的第一个纹身。我纹了喜剧和悲剧面孔，还有“纪念查德”的横幅，这是我的第一个纹身。我纹这个的原因很明显。这现在几乎成了家庭象征。最初是我父亲去纹的。
Because this was the tattoo he wanted to get, you know, without the banners. But that's what he wanted to get. That's what he planned on getting the following year for his birthday. I mean, he already had it planned out, you know? And so my father came home with it one day, and he got it.
因为这是他想纹的纹身，你知道，没有那些横幅。但那就是他想纹的。那是他计划在第二年他生日时去纹的。我的意思是，他都已经计划好了，你知道吗？所以有一天父亲带着它回家，他纹好了。
And you and your dad, though, aren't the only ones.
但是你和你父亲并不是唯一的人。
No. There's me and my father, Steve [? Prisbian, ?] Mike [? Richberg, ?] who still works here. My grandmother has the sad face.
不。还有我和我父亲，史蒂夫·普里斯比安（Steve Prisbian），迈克·里奇伯格（Mike Richberg），他现在还在这里工作。我祖母纹了悲伤的面具。
The tattoo?
纹身？
Yeah. She has it on her chest, too. And Eric [INAUDIBLE], who worked here, has it also.
是的。她也纹在胸前。还有埃里克，他也在这里工作，也纹了。
And it's good. It's nice to see people. There's probably, all together, 15 people that have his name tattooed on them. We used to sit around the kitchen table, and take a needle and wrap thread around it, and dip it in calligraphy ink and tattoo each other with it.
这很好。很高兴看到人们纹身。总共大概有15个人把他的名字纹在身上。我们以前常围坐在厨房桌子旁，拿一根针绕上线，蘸着书法墨水互相纹身。
And there's quite a few people who we masterfully tattooed Chad's name on their arm. Whether they like it now or not, it's still there.
还有不少人，我们熟练地把查德的名字纹在他们手臂上。不管他们现在喜不喜欢，它依然在那里。
They've tried to stay as close to Chad's vision of the restaurant as possible. He never specified decor, so they've had a free hand there. He and Mike actually drafted a menu for the place, and the families kept about half of it. The other half was slow baking recipes that no customer would ever wait for.
他们一直试图尽可能接近查德对餐馆的愿景。他从未具体指定装饰，所以他们在这里有自由发挥的空间。他和迈克实际上为这个地方起草了一份菜单，家庭保留了大约一半。另一半是慢炖菜谱，没有顾客会愿意等那么久。
Chad was also a lot of fun, everyone says. A lot of fun. A comedian. And they say that's why they joke around so much at Chad's Trading Post.
每个人都说，查德也很有趣。很有趣。一个喜剧演员。他们说这就是为什么他们在“查德的交易站”开这么多玩笑的原因。
Scott says when he sees a heavyset customer that comes in a lot, he says, hey, tubby. He builds towers of little creamer packages on the bald head of another customer. Glenn throws crumpled up napkins at his employees. They have water fights. All this levity in a place that's essentially a large roadside memorial that serves massive omelettes.
斯科特说，当他看到一个经常来的体型肥胖的顾客时，他会说，嘿，胖子。他在另一个顾客的秃头上堆起小份奶油包。格伦往员工身上扔揉成团的餐巾纸。他们还会打水仗。所有这些轻松愉快，都在这个本质上是一个供应巨型煎蛋的巨大路边纪念馆里。
If Chad was here, we'd have the place upside down by now.
如果查德在这里，我们现在早就把这个地方翻天覆地了。
How do you mean?
你是怎么说的？
Oh, it's in fun, you know? We really have fun now. But I think if he was here, we wouldn't have all that tension of his passing on our shoulder. The only tension we'd have is how much trouble we're going to get into.
哦，那只是在开玩笑，你知道吗？我们现在真的玩得很开心。但我认为如果他在这里，我们就不会有那种他在我们肩膀上离世的压力。我们唯一的紧张就是我们将陷入多大的麻烦。
Because I've got to say, I mean, when I was here with Mary Ellen, we didn't know anything about the restaurant either, obviously. We just found it. And the first thing we saw was the menu, and then we saw the back of Scott's shirt. It was a little creepy, in a way.
因为我得说，当我和玛丽·艾伦在这里时，我们显然对这家餐馆一无所知。我们只是发现了它。我们看到的第一件事是菜单，然后我们看到了斯科特衬衫的背面。这在某种程度上有点诡异。
I've never gotten that response before. I've never gotten the response that it was creepy. I always got the response that that's a very nice thing to do. It's very genuine, and it's heartwarming. I've never gotten creepy before.
我以前从来没收到过那种回应。我从来没收到过它是诡异的回应。我总是得到的回应是那是一件非常好的事。它是非常真诚的，令人心暖的。我以前从来没听过“诡异”这个评价。
Well I just mean that it's like there's somebody else here in the restaurant that's not really here. But you know what I mean?
好吧，我只是说，感觉餐馆里有别人，虽然他并不真正在这里。但你明白我的意思吗？
And that's exactly what it is. He's here. He's here with us, and we kind of have to yell at him once in a while, because every time something silly or stupid happens, you've got to blame somebody. And he's one to pull a prank on me for that, so oh, he's definitely here. But there's nothing creepy about it.
而那正是它的样子。他在那里。他和我们在一起，我们有时不得不对他大喊，因为每次发生什么愚蠢或白痴的事，你都得怪罪某人。而且他是个会对我开玩笑的人，所以，哦，他肯定在这里。但这没什么诡异的。
I think I can safely say I have never seen any other family keep someone alive to this degree. They've gone out of their way to construct a world where they couldn't possibly forget Chad. A jumbo-sized photo of Chad stood behind Scott and his wife at their wedding.
我想我可以肯定地说，我从未见过其他任何家庭能把某人保持在如此高的活跃度。他们不遗余力地构建了一个他们不可能忘记查德的世界。查德的巨幅照片站在斯科特和他妻子婚礼的背景里。
They believe Chad has protected their lives in serious accidents-- that he brought Mike's son through a recent infection unscathed. Chad's room is the same as it was the day he was shot in it, with two exceptions. They took down the girlie pictures from the wall, and they replaced the carpet.
他们相信查德在严重的事故中保护了他们的生命——是他让迈克的孩子免受最近一次感染的影响。查德的房间和他被枪杀那天一模一样，只有两个例外。他们从墙上取下了女孩照片，换了地毯。
Before they did all this, right after Chad died, they all say they were lost. Mike said he wanted to crawl into a hole. Scott and his father had to make a deal with each other-- that neither would kill himself. Scott and Cory went into counseling. Scott says it didn't help much.
在他们做这一切之前，就在查德去世后，他们都说他们迷失了。迈克说他想钻进一个洞里。斯科特和他的父亲不得不达成协议——两人都不会自杀。斯科特和科里接受了心理咨询。斯科特说没太大帮助。
But that's how it was when it happened. I mean, I didn't know what to do. I had no idea what to do.
但事情发生时就是那样。我的意思是，我不知道该做什么。我根本不知道该做什么。
I walked in the bathroom, and I look in the mirror, and I'm just staring at myself in the mirror. And I flipped out and started punching the mirror. So now both my hands are cut, and I'm bleeding all over the place and sitting on the floor crying. And I have no idea why. You know, when you're that old, and something like that happens, you don't have any idea what to do in any circumstance.
我走进浴室，看着镜子，只是盯着镜子里的自己。然后我崩溃了，开始猛击镜子。所以现在我的两只手都割破了，到处都是血，坐在地板上哭。我根本不知道为什么。你知道，当你那么大年纪，发生那样的事时，在任何情况下你都不知道该怎么办。
Walking across a bridge, looking down. Yeah, maybe. You sit there and think about it for a few minutes. It takes a lot out of you. It takes a lot out of your mind, you know? And counseling made it worse for a while.
走过一座桥，往下看。是的，也许吧。你坐在那里想几分钟。它会耗尽你的精力。它会耗尽你的思想，你知道吗？咨询在一段时间内让情况变得更糟。
What made it better-- what Glenn says saved them-- was starting the family business-- Chad's business.
让情况变好的是什么——格伦说救了他们的是——开始家族企业——查德的企业。
But, I guess, is it healthy?
但，我想，这健康吗？
I think everybody grieves in a different way. For me, it is, because I'm doing something constructive. I was semi-retired and disabled before. I'm still disabled, but I was just vegging. I was sitting at home feeling sorry for myself and doing nothing.
我认为每个人哀悼的方式不同。对我来说，是健康的，因为我在做一些有建设性的事。我之前半退休且残疾。我仍然残疾，但我只是在混日子。我坐在家里为自己感到难过，什么也不做。
When the restaurant idea came up from his brother Scott, and we started looking into it rather seriously, and we found the place, it was almost like a breath of fresh air. It was something we could all do in memory of his brother and have some fun with it. And we have, for seven years.
当他弟弟斯科特提出餐馆的想法时，我们开始认真研究，找到了这个地方，这简直像是一股新鲜空气。这是我们所有人都能为了纪念他的兄弟而做的事，并从中得到乐趣。我们已经做了七年了。
Healthy? I don't know. I mean, the psychiatrists say many different things. People who blithely say "things will get better over time" have never been here. Things never get better. They get a little less immediate.
健康吗？我不知道。我的意思是，精神科医生说了很多不同的事。那些轻率地说“事情会随时间好转”的人从来没经历过这些。事情永远不会好转。它们只会变得不那么直接。
So we work this in memory of him, as a way of keeping him immediate to us. Nobody forgets. And we get along this way. We get by this way. A whole bunch of us get by this way.
所以我们为了纪念他而经营这里，作为一种让他对我们保持直接联系的方式。没有人会忘记。我们就这样相处。我们就这样过活。我们这一大群人就靠这个过活。
In Northampton, where I used to live, there's a couple, and they own a cafe. And at one point, they had a child who lived 19 days. And after they disconnected him from life support, they built a shrine in their restaurant for him. Pictures of him connected to white tubes dotted the walls and beams. And his father, a musician, would perform a song at the cafe-- weekly, as I remember it-- comparing his son to a salmon and to the Messiah.
在北安普敦，我以前住的地方，有一对夫妻，他们开了一家咖啡馆。有一次，他们有个孩子只活了19天。在他们切断生命支持后，他们在餐馆里为他建了一个神龛。照片上连接着白色管子的他散落在墙壁和横梁上。他的父亲，一位音乐家，会每周在咖啡馆表演一首歌——我记得——把他的儿子比作一条鲑鱼和一个弥赛亚。
And some of us, at first, though we knew it had to be hard, felt a little embarrassed for them, as though this tragedy had driven them a little crazy. I think it's hard for us to know exactly what to do or say when we see public mourning like this, because we see it so rarely. The intensity of it is shocking. It's too naked.
我们有些人起初，虽然知道这一定很艰难，但觉得为他们感到有点尴尬，好像这场悲剧让他们变得有点疯狂。我想当我们看到这样的公开哀悼时，很难确切地知道该做什么或说什么，因为我们很少见到。它的强度令人震惊。它太赤裸了。
And usually, we think that if you hold onto someone after their death this way, you can't live your own life. But clearly, you can.
而且通常，我们认为如果你在某人死后这样执着，你就无法过自己的生活。但显然，你可以。
Sean Cole is a producer of our program. In the years since we first broadcast this story, Chad's Trading Post closed down. The family kept Chad's memory alive in a new restaurant called Chad's Good Table 10 minutes away. Then they sold that restaurant off in 2011.
肖恩·科尔是我们节目的制片人。在我们首次播出这个故事以来的几年里，“查德的交易站”关闭了。这个家庭在10分钟路程外的一家名为“查德的好餐桌”（Chad's Good Table）的新餐馆里延续了对查德的纪念。后来他们在2011年卖掉了那家餐馆。
Act Three, Wait, Wait, Don't Film Me. Now this origin story. Our colleague at WBEZ and the host of the public radio show Wait, Wait, Don't Tell Me, Mr. Peter Sagal, used to be a playwright. And to give you a sense of the kind of work that he did as a playwright, his most successful play, he says, was about a Holocaust denier and the Jewish attorney who represented that Holocaust denier in court.
第三幕，“等一下，别拍我”。现在这个起源故事。我们在 WBEZ 的同事、公共广播节目《等一下，别告诉我》的主持人彼得·萨加尔先生，曾经是一位剧作家。为了让你了解他作为剧作家所做的工作类型，他说他最成功的剧作是关于一个大屠杀否认者和在法庭上为该否认者辩护的犹太律师的故事。
And so it was all intellectual arguments and drama, and it involved the Holocaust and questions of the First Amendment law. And it came to the attention of this producer, Lawrence Bender, who is most well known for being Quentin Tarantino's producer. So he produced, among many other movies, Reservoir Dogs and Pulp Fiction and so on and so forth.
所以这全是知识性的争论和戏剧性，涉及到大屠杀和第一修正案法律的问题。它引起了制片人劳伦斯·本德（Lawrence Bender）的注意，他最出名的是作为昆汀·塔伦蒂诺（Quentin Tarantino）的制片人。他制作了包括《落水狗》（Reservoir Dogs）、《低俗小说》（Pulp Fiction）在内的许多电影。
Back in the '90s, when all this happened, Bender read Peter's play, and liked it, and called him up, and asked Peter if he wanted to write a movie. And Peter basically had been waiting for this phone call from Hollywood forever.
回到90年代这一切发生的时候，本德读了彼得的剧本，很喜欢，于是打电话给他，问彼得是否想写一部电影。彼得基本上一直在等待这个来自好莱坞的电话。
I think the year of 1992, my annual income was $10,000. Yeah. This was the phone call that you wait for.
我想1992年那年，我的年收入是1万美元。是的。这就是你一直在等的那个电话。
So after tossing around some different ideas for this film, Lawrence Bender introduces Peter to this woman who he works with, who, at 15, had been an American in Cuba when the Cuban Revolution happened. Maybe there's a film in that. So Peter start writing this film that's half romance growing up film, half politics, about an American teenage girl in Cuba in the '50s.
因此，在为这部电影抛出一些不同的点子后，劳伦斯·本德把彼得介绍给了他合作的一位女性，她在15岁时就是古巴革命发生时的一名美国人。也许那里有一部电影。所以彼得开始写这部电影，这是一部半成长 romance 电影，半政治电影，关于一个50年代古巴的美国少女。
And I didn't know anything about the Cuban Revolution. But one of the things I found out was that everybody involved with it was incredibly young. Castro himself was only 29. They were all 17, 18, 19, 20 years old, these guys up in the mountains with him.
我当时对古巴革命一无所知。但我发现的一件事是，所有参与其中的人都极其年轻。卡斯特罗本人只有29岁。他们都只有17、18、19、20岁，这些和他在山上的家伙。
And one of the things that actually happened was almost as soon as they took over, the Cuban Revolution, these wonderful young Democrats-- you know, freedom-loving rebels from the mountains-- started executing people on television. And in my original conception, there were two parallel stories. There was Maria, who I called the central character, who had a rebellious, more typically adolescent rebellion going against her own parents. And then there was her romantic interest, a character named [? Josefo, ?] who was a Cuban, and was a sort of a third column rebel underground guy, living and working in Havana to undermine the regime, sometimes through violence.
实际上发生的一件事是，几乎在他们接管古巴革命后，这些奇妙的年轻民主党人——你知道，来自山上的热爱自由的叛军——开始在电视上处决人。在我最初的构思中，有两条平行故事。一个是玛丽亚，我称之为核心人物，她有一种叛逆、更典型的青春期叛逆，去反抗她自己的父母。然后是她的浪漫兴趣，一个名叫 Josefo 的角色，他是古巴人，是一个在哈瓦那生活和工作以削弱政权的第三纵队地下反叛者，有时通过暴力。
And eventually, this film did get made.
最终，这部电影确实制作出来了。
It did.
确实。
It did. It finally got made a bit later. And I'm just going to play a clip here from it.
确实。它终于在稍后制作出来了。我只是要在这里播放一段剪辑。
Oh, God, I love dancing with him.
哦，天哪，我喜欢和他跳舞。
Did it ever occur to you that that boy might be using you?
你有没有想过那个男孩可能在利用你？
What? What?
什么？什么？
A nice American girl--
一个可爱的美国女孩——
No.
不。
--who can be used to get out of here.
——可以被用来离开这里。
Please. No, that's not true.
请。不，那不是真的。
You may love dancing with that boy, but there are more important factors here, like your family and your future!
你可能喜欢和那个男孩跳舞，但这里有更重要的因素，比如你的家庭和未来！
Why does it have to be either or? Just because you gave up your passion, why should I?
为什么必须是二选一？仅仅因为你放弃了你的热情，为什么我也要放弃？
[SLAP]
[耳光]
So that's a clip from the film. You want to just let people know the title of the film?
所以那是电影的一个片段。你想告诉大家电影的名字吗？
The title of the film is Dirty Dancing 2 , Colon, Havana Nights.
电影的名字是《辣身舞2：哈瓦那之夜》（Dirty Dancing 2: Havana Nights）。
I have to say, I watched the movie last night. I watched Dirty Dancing.
我必须说，我昨晚看了那部电影。我看了《辣身舞》。
The whole thing?
整部电影？
Yeah.
是的。
There is not a single line of dialogue in that movie that I wrote.
那部电影里没有一句台词是我写的。
So how does a film go from political coming-of-age drama to Dirty Dancing 2-- Havana Nights ? Well, of course, it's an old Hollywood story. Peter writes his film. He turns it in. They ask him to make it more like-- oh, maybe could it be more like Dirty Dancing, innocent girl with a semi-dangerous guy.
那么一部电影是如何从政治成长剧变成《辣身舞2：哈瓦那之夜》的呢？嗯，当然，这是一个古老的好莱坞故事。彼得写了他的电影。他交了上去。他们让他把它变得更像——哦，也许可以更像《辣身舞》，天真的女孩和一个稍微危险的家伙。
And sometimes I think back on the experience, and I say, you know, I should have said to them, hey, if that's what you want, I'm really not the guy for it.
有时我回想起这次经历，我说，你知道，我应该对他们说，嘿，如果那是你想要的，我真的不是合适的人选。
He says each draft got worse and worse. Even he didn't like it. Finally, it was shelved.
他说每一稿都变得越来越糟。连他自己都不喜欢。最后，它被搁置了。
Years later, the producer who actually owned the rights to the film Dirty Dancing teamed up with Lawrence Bender to make a sequel, and somebody thought of Peter's old script. All the politics of the film got reduced to this one moment where, really, unconnected to anything else in the film, somebody attempts to shoot some unidentified political figure at the climax of the dance contest. And then later, in a moment of obligatory foreshadowing, our couple talks about whether Castro would ever kick out Americans from Cuba.
多年后，真正拥有《辣身舞》电影版权的制片人与劳伦斯·本德联手制作了一部续集，有人想到了彼得的旧剧本。电影的所有政治意义都被削减到了这一个时刻，即在舞蹈比赛的高潮，有人试图向某个未指明的政治人物开枪，这确实与电影中的任何其他内容无关。后来，在一段必须的前兆时刻，我们的这对情侣谈论卡斯特罗是否会把美国人赶出古巴。
I'm just saying that--
我只是说——
What? That I might have to leave?
什么？我可能不得不离开？
It could happen.
这可能会发生。
But they wouldn't do that. Not if the whole idea is to give people their freedom.
但他们不会那样做。如果整个想法是给人们自由的话，就不会。
Can I ask you what it was like for you to watch the film? For you to sit in a theater and watch the film?
我能问问你看这部电影是什么感觉吗？你坐在剧院里看这部电影？
It was fine. It was really fine, because--
很好。真的很好，因为——
Oh, honey.
哦，亲爱的。
No, no, no. I mean this. Let me put it this way. Before I got that call, this experience had been a failure.
不，不，不。我是认真的。让我这样说吧。在接到那个电话之前，这种经历是一次失败。
I mean, I remember at that time just lying in bed going, well, I had my shot and I blew it. All I ever wanted was a shot, and I got my shot, and it failed. I did a bad job.
我的意思是，我记得当时躺在床上想着，好吧，我有机会了，但我搞砸了。我想要的只是一个机会，我得到了机会，但我失败了。我做得很糟糕。
And so then when I got the phone call, it's like, oh, it's going to be made, and it's going to be Dirty Dancing 2, that's a happy ending. That's a much better ending than the ending I thought I had, which was that it was just a disaster.
所以当我接到那个电话时，就像，哦，它要拍出来了，而且它是《辣身舞2》，那是一个快乐的结局。那比我原以为的结局好得多，那是个灾难。
Act Four, Bill Clinton's Seven-Year-Old Brother. So reporter Mary Wiltenburg spent a year writing about two boys-- brothers who were born in a Tanzanian refugee camp, and then resettled in Georgia in 2006. Many of her stories are focused on the older brother, nine-year-old Bill Clinton Hadam. His dad is a big fan of the former president. After a tough first year in the United States, Bill seemed to have settled in. But his little brother Igey was still struggling to understand his own origin story-- to get his seven-year-old brain around who he was and where he came from.
第四幕，“比尔·克林顿七岁的弟弟”。记者玛丽·威尔滕堡（Mary Wiltenburg）花了一年时间写了两个男孩——出生在坦桑尼亚难民营，然后于2006年重新定居在佐治亚州的兄弟。她的许多故事都集中在大哥、九岁的比尔·克林顿·哈达姆（Bill Clinton Hadam）身上。他的父亲是这位前总统的忠实粉丝。在在美国度过了艰难的第一年后，比尔似乎已经安顿下来了。但他弟弟伊格（Igey）还在努力理解他自己的起源故事——试图让七岁的大脑弄清楚他是谁以及他从哪里来。
At this point, Mary has spent so much time with these two boys that she's more than a reporter. She's more like a member of the family. Anyway, here's Mary.
在这一点上，玛丽和这两个男孩共处的时间太长了，她不仅是一位记者。她更像是这个家庭的一员。总之，那是玛丽。
Igey calls me on the phone almost every day. Sometimes he leaves messages.
伊格几乎每天都给我打电话。有时他会留言。
First unheard message.
第一条未听留言。
Hi! Hello, Mary. This is me, Igey, and the good news is Bill is going to summer school, and I'm not going to summer school. OK, this is me, Igey. OK, bye.
嗨！你好，玛丽。是我，伊格，好消息是比尔要去上暑期学校，而我不用。好的，是我，伊格。好的，再见。
In between the messages, we have long chats. I tape most of our conversations, because I'm writing these articles about him and his family. And the conversations always seem to start with one of two questions. When can I come to your house, or when are you coming to my house?
在留言之间，我们有很长的聊天。我录下了我们大部分的对话，因为我正在写关于他和家人的文章。对话似乎总是以两个问题之一开始。我什么时候能去你家，或者你什么时候来我家？
Hello?
喂？
Mary? Are you almost here?
玛丽？你快到了吗？
Oh, I'm going to be there soon. I'm in the car right now driving to you, and there's a little bit of traffic.
哦，我很快就到。我现在在车里开车去你那里，路上有点拥堵。
You're driving now?
你现在在开车？
I'm driving right now.
我现在在开车。
You're coming to take us though, right?
你答应过带我们去，对吧？
I am, yes.
是的，我是。
So you know I'm crazy about this kid. He's sweet, nosy, funny. He's been to my house a bunch since I started doing these stories. But the first time he came over, six months ago, he announced to me and my husband and his brother, Bill Clinton, that from now on, the first grader formerly known as Igey, would be going by his middle name, John.
所以你知道我多喜欢这孩子。他很甜，爱打听，有趣。自从我开始做这些故事以来，他已经去过我家里好几次了。但六个月前他第一次来时，他向我和我丈夫以及他哥哥比尔·克林顿宣布，从现在开始，原名伊格的一年级学生将使用他的中间名，约翰（John）。
I'd already known something was up, because that afternoon, my husband took Igey to the park. Igey was up on the jungle gym when a girl about the same age called over from the swingset and asked his name. And he got all weird and wouldn't answer her. She thought he hadn't heard her, so she hopped off the swing, came over to the jungle gym, and asked him again, what's your name? Igey got this kind of cornered look and said, I don't know my name.
我之前就知道有事要发生，因为那天下午，我丈夫带伊格去公园。伊格在攀爬架上时，一个和他差不多大的女孩从秋千架那边问他的名字。他变得很奇怪，没回答她。她以为他没听见，于是跳下秋千，来到攀爬架旁，又问了一遍，你叫什么名字？伊格露出了一种被困住的表情说，我不知道我的名字。
But by later that night, he seemed to have made a decision. He was now John. In our living room, he struggled to type his new name into a video game. J-O-- wait, was it J or G? Then Bill offered to help. Igey said, I know how to spell my own name.
但到了那天晚上晚些时候，他似乎做出了决定。他现在是约翰。在我们的客厅里，他努力把他的新名字打进电子游戏里。J-O——等等，是 J 还是 G？然后比尔提出帮忙。伊格说，我知道怎么拼写我自己的名字。
Igey picked up English first and best of anyone in his family, but his teachers say Igey's more confused about where he's from and who he is than other seven year olds they've seen. And the charter school Igey and Bill attend is about half refugees. So you'd think they'd see a lot of this.
伊格在家庭成员中第一个学会了英语而且学得最好，但他的老师说伊格比他们见过的其他七岁孩子更困惑于自己从哪里来以及他是谁。伊格和比尔就读的特许学校里大约有一半是难民。所以你以为他们会经常看到这种情况。
Teachers say no. Little kids usually realize pretty fast that most people who ask "where are you from," they don't want the whole story. And it doesn't really matter if you say you're from Burma, where your parents were from, or Thailand, where you lived in the camp. In first grade, you just pick one and get on with your day.
老师说没有。小孩子通常很快意识到，大多数问“你从哪里来”的人，并不想听整个故事。如果你说你来自缅甸，你的父母来自那里，或者来自泰国，你在营地住过，这其实无关紧要。在一年级，你只要选一个，然后过好你的一天。
But for Igey, where are you from has never felt that simple. All winter, he seemed to be revising his story. First, he denied the camp he'd lived in his whole life. Hated the word refugee.
但对伊格来说，“你从哪里来”从来没觉得那么简单。整个冬天，他似乎都在修改他的故事。首先，他否认了他住了一辈子的营地。讨厌“难民”这个词。
Then he started saying he wasn't from Congo, his nationality, or Tanzania, where he was born, or Africa at all. He'd say, I'm from here, or America. Watching TV, he'd point to rich white kids and say, that's me. At home, he threw tantrums.
然后他开始说他不是来自刚果，他的国籍，或者坦桑尼亚，他出生的地方，或者非洲任何地方。他会说，我来自这里，或者美国。看电视时，他会指着富有的白人孩子说，那就是我。在家时，他会发脾气。
At school, he sometimes seemed almost catatonic. He wouldn't answer questions, wouldn't meet people's eyes. His parents, his teachers, everyone felt helpless. They didn't know what set him off or how to reach him.
在学校，他有时看起来几乎是木僵状态。他不回答问题，不与人对视。他的父母，他的老师，每个人都感到无助。他们不知道是什么激怒了他，也不知道该如何接近他。
And he seemed to regress. If he were sitting on the couch, he'd snuggle up or take my hand. The slightest things made him cry. He seemed lost.
而且他似乎在退化。如果他坐在沙发上，他会蜷缩起来或拉着我的手。最细微的事情都会让他哭。他似乎迷失了。
One night on the phone, I reminded him where he was born-- in Tanzania. I'm from Tanzania, he said?
一天晚上在电话里，我提醒他出生在哪里——在坦桑尼亚。我来自坦桑尼亚？他说？
I'm from Tanzania?
我来自坦桑尼亚？
Uh-huh.
嗯。
I am?
我是吗？
Well, that's where you were born.
嗯，那是你出生的地方。
No! But where am I from?
不！但你是从哪里来的？
Well, you were born in Tanzania, and you dad came from Congo.
嗯，你出生在坦桑尼亚，你爸爸来自刚果。
I was?
我是吗？
And your mom came from Rwanda. So your family has a lot of places where you're from.
你妈妈来自卢旺达。所以你的家庭有很多来自的地方。
OK. Bye.
好的。再见。
Bye.
再见。
Igey's parents didn't mind calling him John. They were just kind of puzzled. The idea that you could hate your name seemed like one more baffling thing about America. They just had no idea what Igey was going through, and it made Igey feel more distant from them.
伊格的父母不介意叫他约翰。他们只是有点困惑。你能讨厌你名字的想法似乎是关于美国的又一件令人困惑的事。他们根本不知道伊格经历了什么，这让伊格觉得离他们更远了。
A while back, I was riding with Igey and his parents in their car when he said to me, I don't want to live with my mom. I thought it was a setup for one of his jokes. So I said, you don't want to live with your mom? Why?
前阵子，我和伊格以及他的父母在他们的车里时，他对我说，我不想和我的妈妈住在一起。我以为这又是他在开玩笑。所以我说，你不想和你妈妈住在一起？为什么？
He said, I want to live with you. I said, no, you don't want to live with me. But then Igey got all serious and said, but what if I forget my language? I said, what do you mean? And he said, if I forget my language, I can't live with them, because they won't understand me. Later, on the phone, we talked about what it's like for him talking with his mom.
他说，我想和你住在一起。我说，不，你不想和我住在一起。但伊格变得很严肃，说，但如果我忘记了我的语言怎么办？我说，你是什么意思？他说，如果我忘记了我的语言，我就不能和他们住在一起，因为他们会听不懂我的话。后来，在电话里，我们谈论了他和他妈妈交谈的感觉。
When you speak English, does she understand you?
当你讲英语时，她能听懂吗？
No.
不能。
So maybe you're learning faster, huh?
所以也许你学得更快，嗯？
I just forget it right now.
我只是现在忘了它。
Swahili?
斯瓦希里语？
Yes.
是的。
Like, what do you forget?
比如，你忘了什么？
Everything.
一切。
And then at some point this spring, Igey just went back to being Igey. A lot of things happened for him at once. His green card arrived. His reading took off. It took me a while to notice that John had vanished.
然后今年春天某个时候，伊格又变回了伊格。很多事情同时发生在他身上。他的绿卡到了。他的阅读能力突飞猛进。我花了一段时间才注意到约翰消失了。
His teachers don't remember, either, exactly when he stopped correcting them. But by the last month of school, he was taking his turn in the semicircle with everyone else. No drama. Just, my name is Igey, and I'm from Congo.
他的老师也不记得他确切是什么时候停止纠正他们的。但到学期的最后一个月，他和其他人一样在半圆圈里轮流发言。没有戏剧性。只是，我叫伊格，我来自刚果。
And suddenly, he was volunteering details about his life in the camp. Games he played, his mud brick house. Igey seemed to be making peace with his past and his name. And he moved on to other burning seven-year-old questions.
突然间，他开始主动说出关于他在营地生活的细节。他玩过的游戏，他的泥砖房。伊格似乎正在与他的过去和名字和解。他转向了其他七岁孩子火热的问题。
What's bingo night mean?
宾果之夜是什么意思？
Oh! [LAUGHING] You know how you play bingo at school?
哦！[笑] 你知道你在学校怎么玩宾果吗？
Yeah.
是的。
It's like a night when a bunch of adults get together. Maybe kids, too. And they play a game that's like that, only with numbers instead of words.
那就像一个晚会，一群成年人聚在一起。也许还有孩子。他们玩一个像那样的游戏，只是用数字而不是单词。
OK. I'm waiting for you, OK?
好的。我在等你，好吗？
OK. I'll see you soon.
好的。我很快就会见到你。
OK. Bye.
好的。再见。
Bye bye.
再见再见。
And just when it seemed like Igey had finally accepted his own name, the other shoe dropped. The last week of school, Igey asked me, "Um, what does gay mean?" I told him gay can mean happy, or it could mean when a man loves another man.
就在伊格似乎终于接受了自己的名字时，另一只鞋落地了。学期的最后一周，伊格问我，“嗯，同性恋（gay）是什么意思？”我告诉他 gay 可以意味着快乐，也可以意味着当一个男人爱另一个男人时。
Igey started sobbing. We were in his kitchen, and he just collapsed against the fridge. Finally, he choked out what was wrong, and it turned out that some second graders had been taunting him. "Igey, you're gay." And he told them, "That's not a word."
伊格开始抽泣。我们在他的厨房里，他只是崩溃着靠在冰箱上。最后，他哽咽着说出了哪里不对劲，原来是一些二年级的学生一直在嘲笑他。“伊格，你是同性恋。”他告诉他们，“那不是一个词。”
It was just one more strike against that name. But for now, John hasn't reappeared. Igey's sticking with Igey.
这对那个名字来说只是又一次打击。但目前，约翰还没有再出现。伊格坚持用伊格这个名字。
The other day, when we were riding in the car, I said some offhand thing about needing to call my mom. Igey said, "You have a mom?" I said, "Yeah, of course." He could not believe it. How had he not known about this before?
前几天，当我们在车里时，我随口说了一句需要给妈妈打电话。伊格说，“你有妈妈？”我说，“是的，当然。”他简直不敢相信。他以前怎么会不知道这件事？
This year, it's been hard enough for Igey to put together his own story. The idea that I-- wait, everybody-- comes from somewhere? It kind of blew his mind.
今年，对伊格来说，整理出他自己的故事已经够难的了。我——等等，每个人——都来自某处这个概念？它有点让他大吃一惊。
Mary Wiltenburg. She wrote about Igey, Bill Clinton, and their family for the Christian Science Monitor. You can read more of her reporting about them at littlebillclinton.csmonitor.com.
玛丽·威尔滕堡。她为《基督教科学箴言报》（Christian Science Monitor）写了关于伊格、比尔·克林顿和他们家庭的文章。你可以在 littlebillclinton.csmonitor.com 阅读更多她关于他们的报道。
Well, our program was produced today by Lisa Pollak and myself, with Alex Blumberg, Sean Cole, Jane Feltes, Sarah Koenig, Alissa Shipp, and Nancy Updike. Our senior producer is Julie Snyder. Production help from JP Dukes.
好了，我们的节目今天由丽莎·波拉克（Lisa Pollak）和我本人制作，亚历克斯·布伦伯格（Alex Blumberg）、肖恩·科尔、简·费尔特斯（Jane Feltes）、莎拉·科尼格、阿丽莎·希普（Alissa Shipp）和南希·厄普代克（Nancy Updike）协助。我们的高级制片人是朱莉·斯奈德（Julie Snyder）。JP 杜克斯（JP Dukes）提供了制作帮助。
Seth Lind is our operations director. Emily Condon's our production manager. Elise Bergerson's our office manager. Adrianne Mathiowetz runs the website. Music help from Jessica Hopper.
塞斯·林德（Seth Lind）是我们的运营总监。艾米丽·康顿（Emily Condon）是我们的制作经理。伊莉斯·伯格森（Elise Bergerson）是我们的办公室经理。阿德里安娜·马蒂奥维茨（Adrianne Mathiowetz）运营网站。杰西卡·霍珀（Jessica Hopper）提供了音乐帮助。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org. Thanks today to Bob [? Folkenflik ?], Matt Holtzman, and Hank Rosenfeld. Pino Audia's research paper about garages and entrepreneurs that I talked about at the beginning of the show was done with Christopher Rider.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org。今天感谢鲍勃·福肯弗利克（Bob Folkenflik）、马特·霍尔兹曼（Matt Holtzman）和汉克·罗森菲尔德（Hank Rosenfeld）。我在节目开头提到的皮诺·奥迪亚关于车库和企业家的研究论文是与克里斯托弗·莱德（Christopher Rider）共同完成的。
Dan Heath, who I also talked to at the top of the show, is the co-author of the book Made to Stick-- Why Some Ideas Survive and Others Die. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Torey Malatia, who hears himself quoted in these credits every single week and says--
我在节目开始时谈到的丹·希思是《粘性：为什么某些想法能存活而另一些会死亡》（Made to Stick）一书的合著者。本节目由 PRX，公共广播交换（Public Radio Exchange）分发到公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人托瑞·马拉蒂亚（Torey Malatia），他每周都在这些字幕中听到自己被引用，然后说——
I never said that. I would never say that.
我没说过那样的话。我绝不会那样说。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周会有更多《美国生活》的故事。